genna's you can probably tell I do love
the holidays I think we all do it's a
well frankly it's a time of gift giving
and charity unfortunately there's a dark
side the holidays also bring out
dishonest people who take advantage of
others generosity lots of ripoffs out
there and well our friend Andy is going
to warn us about some of these in a
segment called
Andy's holiday scam watch Andy thanks
Conan this first one is called the
Santa's shuffle you walk up to a
Salvation Army Santa to put a dollar in
the kettle but you accidentally pull out
the hundred dollar bill you were going
to mail to your goddaughter you try to
shove it back in your wallet but it's
too late
Santa saw it and he's all oh thank you
sir so generous so you gotta put it in
the kettle and just like that a one
dollar kindness cost you a hundred screw
Andy that's that's not really a scam
this next scam is called the charity
cheat your cousin Jeannine donates 80
bucks to a charity in your name great
Jeannine just added your name to a
charity mailing list one day they sends
you mailing labels with your address on
them you can't just throw them out
because what if someone goes through
your recycling so you put them in the
shredder all at once and it jams when
you try and unjam it with your finger
the shredder starts again and nearly
cuts it off the visit to the emergency
room cost you nine hundred and eighty
bucks hey cousin Janine I'm donating
this finger in your name
[Applause]
again Andy that's not really a scam I'm
talking about holiday phishing scams
bait and switch offers counterfeit
handbags that kind of thing
uh-huh this last one's called The Secret
Santas stinker you decide to take part
in your office's Secret Santa you're a
nice guy so you put a lot of thought
into the gift you're gonna give but the
guy who's your Santa thinks he's funny
peppers you with useless novelty gifts
like actual pair of bell-bottom pants
yeah good one idiot and this half a
Jackson puzzle why then the next day he
sends you the other half and get this
[ __ ] they don't even match look I
don't know who you are but stop sending
me garbage that's going straight to the
landfill you're not funny and when I
find out who you are I will personally
ask Conan to fire your ass fire your ass
and II I'm your Secret Santa awkward and
he really should the bed this time Conan
tell everyone we've got a great show
tonight
we've got a great show tonight
[Applause]
but then you will be rogue one a Star
Wars story Alan Tudyk is on the show
Alan Tudyk
he's against the revivalist Jimmy take
it away
[Applause]
you